a vigil was held in boulder last night
to honor those who did not survive that
includes officer eric talley who died
trying to stop the shooter
his sister kirsten brooks told us how
she found out he was gone
and how he should be remembered i
checked the news
and the first thing that showed up was
boulder shooting one cop killed
and i immediately screenshotted it and
sent it to my mother
and i said is eric at work and then i
started to text eric
i said hey it's kirsten then i called
him i said hey
i know you're in the middle of this
probably they gave me a call
and didn't hear from him didn't hear
from him
i made it home i made it into my front
door and
my mother called me and
[Applause]
she was just screaming
and she said his daughter had called her
his young daughter
and said nana daddy daddy's dead i
didn't know other people had been killed
yet i just knew at that moment that eric
was gone
and with that everything about eric was
gone
like it's not just eric that's gone it's
it's who he was in my family he loved
being a police officer
he's like it's it's not my job that's
unsafe kirsten
he said it's it's people and he said but
you know he said it it's not a bad job
he said i i there's a lot more good he
was
moving towards working as a drone
operator because he
he talked about the violence in the
world we had a conversation about that
recently and he's like yeah it just
seemed to be getting worse
um and he said i would never want to put
my family through
losing me as their you know their dad or
you know a husband he said that why
would i do that because that'd be stupid
so um i know that he didn't he never put
himself at risk